Mitzi hi how's it going oh so nice to
meet you I'm good you know I looked at
your pictures and you know you looked
young you look younger in person oh
thank you thank you like uh like a baby
oh that young yeah well
it's kind of it's not the best thing
like a baby with a lot of hair oh hairy
baby yeah
thank you all right this is kibitzing
with Mitzi I'm here with Justin Long
Drew Barrymore said you were funny
why
I don't know that I am funny necessarily
uh I had a lot of when I'm around funny
people such as yourself I feel well
you're intimidating this is different
because you're very you're trying to
button me up no you're just a legend so
you carry with you a certain amount of
you know gravitas if you don't mind me
saying um but I I think uh I always like
to make jokes I was really little when I
was growing up I was very short so I
that was my way of being was it fun to
be short and have the last name long
that's C yes uh that's really funny were
you making a joke or no it was a genuine
question oh oh I'm sorry did you get a
lot of [__] on the playground you know
like your name opened yourself up to
jokes because long right
short person right uh well I had an
uncle named dick this is true dick long
um I don't know if Drew mentioned that
there's a man named dick long and I
don't know him yes it's his real name
and uh and he was Richard as anybody
insisted on going by dick and the
parents didn't say you know what the
short name for Richard is his dick and
his last name's gonna be long so yeah
let's do that let's call him Richard
they didn't they didn't think of it um
lawn can also be schlong which is what I
got a lot of yeah
yeah that's that was me he would have
loved to have had my name yes yes yes
it's it's a evocative
so um who thinks you're not funny well
um let's see my my Proctologist doesn't
think I'm I'm a hoot so I'm just trying
to make jokes just to relax myself you
know when I'm in certain situations uh
just so we can
have a more thorough examination
I recently had a colonoscopy I'll tell
you best time ever oh really oh yeah the
clean out so good I lost like three
pounds in a day oh that's horrible and
then the next day I said listen doc if
you don't draw out that Twilight I'll
Kill Ya Make It Go real slow don't count
me back from a hundred and knock me out
at 94. you wanna you just want the Full
Speed Ahead I think now that having a
colonoscopy might be one of my new
favorite hobbies I can't wait for the
next one I'm like tell me this is annual
well yeah that I I am
so this is the time where I like to uh
challenge you to uh a spit take I'm
gonna take a sip of my tap water okay
and then you know what to do
um
let's see uh
it would be an honor to uh if you ever
are in need of a proctologist I don't
have I'm not licensed but I would love
to a blunt
where have you been all my life Wow
well listen you know I didn't know what
our chemistry would be but I smell
excitement and mothballs and um a little
chloroform a little chloroform yeah this
has been kibitzing with Mitzi my guest
is Justin Long
Justin schlong